في الرابعه عشره من مايو العام الجاري
تشهد تركيا انتخابات رئاسيه يتوجه خلالها
الناخب التركي لصناديق الاقتراع للادلاء
بصوته لمرشح الرئاسه بموجب النظام
الانتخابي الحالي يمكن الترشح لمنصب
الرئيس اما بتسميه الاحزاب الممثله في
البرلمان لمرشحها او بحصول متقدم على مئه
الف توقيع من الناخبين والتقدم بها للمجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات يتنافس على كرسي
الرئاسه الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
ومرشح الطاوله السداسيه زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمالك الجدار اوغلو ومن بعده
سنان اوغان مرشح وتحالف اتا عن حزب النصر
ينتخب رئيس تركيا من خلال نظام التصويت قد
يمتد لجولتين اذا يجب ان يحصل المرشح على
الاغلبيه المطلقه اكثر من 50% من الاصوات
اذا لم يتمكن اي مرشح من الحصول على
الاغلبيه في الجوله الاولى يخوض المرشحان
الحاصلان على اعلى اصوات جوله الاعاده في
28 من مايو ينتخب المرشح الذي يحصل على
اغلبيه الاصوات الصحيحه في الجوله الثانيه
رئيسا للجمهوريه وكون الرئيس ينتخب مباشره
من الشعب لمده خمس سنوات لا يمكن عزله من
منصبه قبل نهايه فتره ولايته يلعب اثنان
من المحددات دورا بارزا في هذه المنافسه
الاولى هي المهاره الشخصيه للمرشح في
مخاطبه الجمهور واقناعه بانه سيكون الافضل
له والثانيه هي التحالفات السياسيه والثقل
الانتخابي بصفته رئيسا للدوله الدستور
يمنحه العديد من السلطات التنفيذيه
المنصوص عليها بالدستور تشمل اصدار
القوانين وتعيين النواب والوزراء وكبار
المسؤولين ورسمه اطرش سياسه الخارجيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات